Світлошумові гранати і гумові кулі проти демонстрантів, які вже понад 100 днів протестують у Білорусі.
За цей час відбулося півтора десятка недільних маршів протесту, тисячі акцій солідарності,
страйки, а також масові затримання, залякування, побиття, тортури і загибель людей.
І все ж ті, хто не згоден з оголошеною перемогою на виборах Олександра Лукашенка, не здаються, до яких би кроків не вдавалася влада.
Так в одному з районів Мінська через політичну активність його жителів навіть відключили воду.
Місцеві називають це помстою Лукашенка.
Окрім цього, він активно використовує силовиків, які під час останніх акцій не давали протестувальникам сформувати велику колону.
Групи людей одразу розганяли, били і жорстоко затримували. А меморіал пам'яті загиблого Романа Бондаренка зруйнували.
Крім насильства у білоруської влади поки немає іншої стратегії, вважає політолог Григорій Ніжніков.
З огляду на той факт, що силовики посіли усі ключові позиції в системі і навколо Лукашенка, навряд чи вони можуть запропонувати щось інше,
окрім як ще більше репресувати учасників протесту. Я думаю, що це насильство лише робить протест сильнішим.
У даному випадку ми бачимо, що протест - він свого роду хвилеподібний. І багато в чому його сплески спричинені насильством з боку влади.
Певною мірою влада сама собі стріляє в ногу, спираючись на насильство.
Пенсіонери продовжують у Мінську свої протестні акції, ще деякі працівники білоруських підприємств приєдналися до страйку.
Але активність на заводах носить лише точковий, а не масовий характер.
Це відбувається через те, що у протестного руху так і не з'явився лідер, вважає експерт.
В опозиції слабка організація, у неї немає виходів і немає ідей, які могли б об'єднати усі ці соціальні групи.
Правильно було помічено, що не можна продовжувати говорити четвертий місяць протестів "йди геть", коли ця вимога вже не працює.
Повинна бути ідея щодо того, як лідери, які хочуть бути лідерами нової Білорусі, бачать майбутнє країни.
Тим часом одна з лідерок опозиції Світлана Тихановська, перебуваючи у Стокгольмі, вкотре закликала посилити санкції проти режиму Лукашенка.
Єдиний вихід з цієї ситуації - це тиск на режим всередині країни та за її межами. Ось чому зараз ми просимо не лише про індивідуальні санкції,
а про фінансові санкції, цілеспрямовані санкції проти бізнесів та людей, які знаходяться у кишенях Лукашенка.
І ми думаємо, що лише економічний тиск змусить цей режим відступити, адже тоді в них не буде грошей платити спецназу та на інші злочини.
Напередодні Тихановська також оголосила про створення в Білорусі народного трибуналу і "амністію за захоплення Лукашенка
і членів його терористичного угруповання". Йдеться про створення централізованої системи фіксації порушень закону з боку чиновників,
ідеологів і офіцерів, які віддавали і виконували злочинні накази, та збір доказів цих порушень.
Наразі санкції щодо правителя Білорусі Олександра Лукашенка та ще 14 білоруських посадовців вже запровадив Євросоюз.
Серед санкційних заходів - зокрема обмеження в'їзду до ЄС.
Тон федерального уряду Німеччини з огляду на насильство проти демонстрантів також стає дедалі жорсткішим.
Цьому має бути покладено край. Федеральний уряд повторює свій наполегливий заклик: почати конструктивний і відкритий діалог
між урядом країни і Координаційною радою про справедливі та вільні вибори.
Федеральний уряд не забуде, що там майже щодня на вулицях били людей.
І ми не забудемо про тих, кого практично щодня викрадали і піддавали ще більшим тортурам за стінами тюрем.
Упродовж 100 днів протести були і залишаються децентралізованими. І хоча масовість недільних акцій істотно зменшилась,
окремі акції ключових соціальних груп, зокрема лікарів, викладачів вузів, пенсіонерів та студентів, нервують владу і все одно чинять на неї тиск.
Тобто учасники протестів все ж досягли певного успіху, адже найбажаніший для влади варіант розвитку подій став неможливим.
Вони не можуть залишити систему такою, якою вона зараз є. В даному випадку ми будемо спостерігати ці кроки
і результат цих кроків буде залежати від того, яка на них буде реакція і протестувальників, і Росії.
На думку оглядачів, якщо протестна активність почне згасати і тиск на владу зменшиться, результатом стануть міжелітні домовленості,
які влаштують і Росію, і Лукашенка, але не протестувальників.